Nicole está por jugar un juego en la feria de pueblo.
Hay una pared con platos de loza y el objetivo
es romper los más posibles lanzando un proyectil....
mmm... suena fascinante...
Nicole tiene lanzamientos ilimitados durante
un lapso de un minuto.
Por cada plato que rompe Nicole recibe 2 fichas.
Cuesta 5 fichas jugar este juego.
Para que Nicole gane fichas se debe de cumplir
la siguiente desigualdad.
"p" es el número de platos que rompe Nicole.
¿En qué casos ganará Nicole fichas?
Pensemos qué es lo que nos están diciendo aquí.
Aquí tenemos 2 por el número
de platos que rompe Nicole.
Para ganar fichas Nicole debe de obtener más
fichas de las que gasta
y por cada plato que rompe obtiene 2 fichas.
Así es que, este número de aquí, 2 por
el número de platos que rompe,
es el número de fichas que Nicole gana, pero usa 5 fichas para jugar, así es que si restamos esto,
mientras esta cantidad sea mayor que 0 y esto
va a ser mayor que 0 si "2p" es mayor que 5,
si obtiene más fichas de las que gasta,
efectivamente va a ganar fichas.
Veamos los diferentes escenarios y en cual
de estos casos va a ganar fichas.
¿Qué pasa si rompe 1 plato?
Si rompe un plato, va a recibir 2 fichas,
pero pago 5 fichas, así es que pierde 3 fichas.
-3 no es mayor que 0, -3 es menor que 0.
Nicole pierde 3 fichas,
definitivamente este caso no aplica.
Si rompe 2 platos, ella recibe, 2 por 2 = 4
fichas, pero va a haber pagado 5 fichas,
no es una buena situación para ella, tendríamos
del lado izquierdo 4 menos 5, que es -1,
lo cual es menor que 0, pero esto lo puede hacer
mentalmente, si está recibiendo 4 fichas,
pero pago 5 fichas, definitivamente no está
teniendo ganancia.
¿Qué pasa si rompe 3 platos?
Ella recibe, 2 por 3 = 6 fichas, usó 5 fichas,
tiene una ganancia neta de 1 ficha,
este valor es mayor que 0,
así es que este caso sí funciona.
Y este último caso es obvio que va a funcionar,
si funciona cuando rompe 3 platos,
con mayor razón va a funcionar, va a ganar más fichas
cuando rompe 6 platos, pero podemos calcularlo.
Tenemos que gana 2 por 6 = 12 fichas por romper
platos, menos 5 fichas que paga por jugar,
ganaría 7 fichas que son definitivamente
mayor que 0, así es que este caso también funciona.